but we celebrate the arts of the Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
tonight my sciences is so important the
Academy honored them the Academy hunted
them at a special banquet where our
cameras we took our cameras the Beverly
Hilton Eden the evening of March the
27th when the mistress of ceremonies was
the versatile star who has herself been
nominated for Oscars twice for her
glowing performances in front of a
camera and again for accomplishments
behind the camera was Diana cannon
awards presentation dinner tonight we
give Oscars to the following Arriflex
for the spinning mirror reflect shudder
now that allows the camera operator to
see through the lens exactly what he is
photographing accepting it is an Oscar
speech as a theme in Norman's an inocent
of two hours Arnold there light awaken
Cronkite and teaser hold fairly cat for
hindered East and in chosen tankers
the Gordon Eastern Railroad was
presented by me to John Oliver
it's been a wonderful life 72 years
adding to the technology of all these
wonderful things they we have done along
with it you know we have marched hand in
hand with the arts and with the arts and
the sciences we have made this into the
wonderful show business that it is and
if we all look thank you worthy
recipients for their contribution to new
technology and filmmakers but all of us
in front of the cameras and all of you
who go to the movies are the
beneficiaries of their talent